just a quick warning before we get
started due to the nature of this week's
guests content this week's ear biscuit
is going to contain some sexually
explicit conversation so if you don't
think you should be listening to
specifically sexually explicit
conversation you can skip this ear
biscuit and join us next week you've
been warned
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link joining us today
once again from VidCon where we recorded
a handful of ear biscuits is one of the
most notable internet personalities with
a focus on sex education on YouTube Laci
green in case you aren't familiar with
Laci
she describes herself as a sex education
activist and her YouTube channel is home
to her very frank video series about sex
called
sex + the number one sex education show
on YouTube the channel currently has 1.3
million subscribers and has racked up
over a hundred and thirteen million
video views now Laci offers advice and
support that covers a wide variety of
topics here's a few of the titles of her
videos just to give you an idea what she
covers 10 secret vagina facts so
feminism in horror films a is for
abstinence shaving pubes Wow and
transgender adventure no matter what
you're looking for in sex education I
think the point is chances are Laci has
at least one video for you and she has a
great answer for why she titles the
videos the way that she does but we
certainly got into a lot more than just
the titles of the videos we talked to
Laci about her background which includes
growing up in a strict Mormon household
and why she decided to leave the Mormon
religion why she became interested in
sex education and feminist activism in
the first place and what led her to
create her YouTube channel sex Plus and
also her MTV webseries braless that
she's been hosting for going on three
seasons now and also towards the end of
the podcast we talked in depth about the
entire Sam pepper incident she was very
centrally involved in that she recounts
the story from the beginning and helps
us hone in an important message for all
of us in the YouTube community so make
sure that you stick around to listen to
that we really had a great time talking
with Laci
getting to know her and her story and we
know that you'll enjoy this biscuit too
but first we want to Ryan you to check
out our animated song biscuits on our
YouTube channel good mythical morning
you guys know song biscuits we wrote
songs with ear biscuit guests with input
from Twitter and then we release those
on Saturdays well now we've animated our
favorite ones on GMM so make sure you
look for that yeah on Saturdays on the
good mythical morning channel now all to
the biscuit so you've got an interesting
water bottle here that you brought we
provide little waters but you brought
your own thing because you didn't you
didn't know if we were gonna do that for
you
it wasn't it has a built-in cup it does
it's also you know can you describe it
like it's a vagina I assumed I didn't
even have to say that if you I'm gonna
tell you about my water bottle but I'm
gonna do it in terms of of a jacket
there's a lot of parts missing on this
water but I mean that's gonna be a tough
analogy it's a weird water bottle I mean
it's it's got a cusp of that weird I
mean is there a valve right in there no
no you just in the world
it works with it works with gravity
there's no Volvo well there's no boat no
clitoris either I gotta say so I was
expecting Laci to kind of take the
conversation there naturally
oh but yeah I mean you can feel free to
just start there that's well because you
know honestly one of the questions that
we did have for you is you know we're
VidCon yes and this is like the pinnacle
of fan interaction right this is when it
gets real real it is so real out there
right now so when you yes like you said
that like this is the middle of a zombie
apocalypse and we and we can say we've
taken refuge right now but during this
time do you find yourself like how often
do people come up
do what link just did like immediately
ask a question when you describe your
water bottle more specifically just
coming up and being like I really need
some sex advice right now well yeah it
happens oh it does yeah it happens but I
think it happens little mate but when it
did happen what happened people I think
they just kind of hold on to their
questions and then they pull me aside
really you know secretly hey can I ask
you a quick question or hey I love your
work can I just ask you a really quick
question really it's never a good
question question like you've been
asking a question here at VidCon yes
what had I feel like I'm betraying just
about like period stuff sex stuff if the
condom was on right I'm worried that it
broke do you think I should take plan B
you know just kind of like teenagers who
are worried about doing sex right and
there's a lot of concern about a lot of
the urgent questions I get are worried
that like oh my god do I have an STD or
am I like putting myself at risk for
pregnancy even if they're the safest
ever like sometimes II will describe the
safest sex in the world that you can
have as safe as it can be right and
they're still scared and so they have
these questions and this is the type of
email that I get the most - so when
people are talking to me in person and
on email and on Twitter they're urgent
like please it's our right now I already
know what it's about you know it's a sex
fear stuff right and so when you get
those questions in an environment like
VidCon or just on the street wherever
mm-hmm is there a okay I'm gonna take
this time because I can't imagine this
obligation you know we just get asked to
be funny and then do a little bit
something funny and then we move on
right or just a picture yeah which
that's easy compared to what you are
being asked to do no one has ever asked
us about a condom right really we know
we know if your guy's condoms don't work
there's enough children our merch do you
have like a go-to thing which is like
okay I'm gonna give you a short and
sweet answer I'm
be sympathetic and try to or I'm just
gonna be like listen you know I do this
yes for a living but I'm not a doctor
and if you really have the question
about this you like what do you do it's
just like talking to a friend right so
you're like here's what I know about
what you told me
here's the best advice that I can give
you I'm obviously not a doctor if you're
really worried about something please go
see a doctor you know and a lot of times
people are just looking for a little bit
of like someone knows my you know I
struggle my secret my fear my worry
right now so I can be that person for
them right I can be like hey it's okay
like this is a common thing a lot of
people deal with this here's probably
you know based on what you're saying to
me here's probably what's going on you
probably don't have anything to worry
about but if you are worried go get
tested or go to the doctor but you also
can't reply to every email once you
start talking about the emails that you
get no I cannot do that
there's too many emails I mean that
seems like a weighty reality to know
that people are emailing you in
desperation but it's not even feasible
for you to reply to all these people
yeah and if you hired a team yeah that's
true I do have a lot of anxiety about
the amount of email that I get and the
seriousness of some of the questions
like there's some really serious stuff
people come to me with and I cannot
you're right like I cannot handle all of
that myself and I've just had to make a
disclaimer you know on my website if
this is emergency I can't be 911 one you
know I just can't one human being yeah
and this is a lot of stuff across a you
know a huge spectrum of topics to that
I'm not always an expert in you know
right yeah I mean I would say that every
once in a while like we'll see like a
question or somebody will tweet me like
you know this person turns out to be
something like this person really wants
to harm themselves can you guys and if
that happens once every four months for
us I can imagine that happens once every
four hours for you yeah it happens a lot
more because I think people feel like
they can't talk to me about it yeah so
they do yeah
yeah when you're so I mean how would you
describe
you know your tone it blatantly honest
in your face just how do you describe it
yeah I think those are good words to
describe what I do I think it's really
Frank and also very friendly you know
I'm a friend that's the way that I think
of my relationship with the people that
watch my videos is I'm not your doctor
I'm not your teacher I'm not your lawyer
I'm not this I'm your friend I happen to
have a little bit more knowledge about
some of these areas so I could probably
help you out but then the day I'm just a
friend and I'm just a person you know
who happens to be interested in these in
these Olympics and I do my homework and
stuff so I try to help people out
because I'm pretty good at research and
you know I have a lot of research
training in my education so I think that
I can bring that skill set to people and
make information more accessible so I
think those are the types of you know
the way that people digest my content in
the way that I see it mm-hmm and you
found yourself being the modern-day dr.
Ruth of the Internet is that a title
that you'll own dr. J character I don't
know if I can compare myself to her
she's a hoot it she's still living right
yes but did you but have you liked what
came first were you already doing this
and then you found out about dr. Ruth or
do you know about dr. Ruth like like
growing up I knew about doctorate oh
come on doctor I don't know we're old
you didn't know about dr. no we did but
we think no sometimes we don't know okay
for the past 15 years maybe she's
falling out of vogue yeah yeah I think
people know who dr. Ruth is relevant
Cultural Revolution
you own the title doctor yeah I don't
mean like on the domain name I just mean
like are you comfortable
you should have biz Netcom monarchy dr.
Ruth or the Internet
no I don't really own that as my title I
guess a lot of people use that to
describe me but I guess they just see it
as a little bit different what I do how
much she does um I don't know you don't
have the accent and she's a little bit
more harsh
she's kind of got like a he's crotchety
which seems like a weird pun yeah she is
she's a little bit more like taking it
you know she doesn't want to mess around
or like deal with your feelings I'm I'm
more okay with talking about feelings
you like how are you doing like the
emotional dilation
your style is different but that that's
why you're the modern-day Internet
version of her right so you're saying
I'm like that the 2.0 yes dr. Ruth 2.0
okay I'll take it I'll take it you are
now taking that I'm taking I'm owning it
but it definitely dumb you know so it
you have been described that way by like
it seems like the kind of thing that
like if like a traditional news outlet
is trying to explain who you are that's
with it that would be like the go-to we
think like traditional news outlets what
we're trying to say dr. Ruth demonic dr.
Ruth except I'm not a doctor they don't
really they call me Laci this expert a
word sexpert is a word people use that
word to describe me too I feel very
uncomfortable with any of the really
authoritative titles right like dr.
expert all of these things I'm not a
doctor like that's a formal designation
right but even expert is thrown around a
little bit more especially in the
internet age like who's an expert what
makes you an expert and people have
referred to me as an expert but sexpert
is just so wait it's just like okay
don't take me too seriously not really
an expert I'm a sexpert right it's kind
of like a little bit of a sexual and
obviously I mean sexually
but it's like sexualized a little bits
like yeah like I'm a sex for at least
that's how I've heard people use it and
when people use it to describe me I feel
like I'm okay with it which is it we
want to get into that too because we
want to but I think we should save it
because we want to get into the some of
the the do's and don'ts for things
people terminology people should avoid
in your opinion but let's get back to
the Oh
origin of all of this the origin of Laci
and how you got to this place where you
are this person that speaks to so many
people about these subjects in a
powerful way so let's go back to the
very beginning where you from where am i
from
well I grew up in Portland Oregon came
over to Sacramento and now in the Bay
Area State on the west coast yeah when
West Coast girl for sure and your
parents are like an interesting combo of
Awesomeness yeah that's about that my
parents are really awesome I didn't
always feel that way and I'm pretty open
about that online which creates a little
bit of awkwardness between us it's a
little real but yeah they are Mormon and
I grew up Mormon so that has been a
really played a really big role in
getting me to where I'm at and your dad
is Iranian yes yeah he's from Iran and
your mom is like what you would picture
a Mormon to be white lady she's a white
lady daddy's like a pretty
he's pretty white for an Iranian - okay
like every we have like olivey skin my
dad does a little bit but he's pretty
white looking as well which is why
people don't usually pick up that you
know half my family's from Iran how did
they meet they met in college they both
went to BYU which was at that time
called Rick's College and it was just a
junior college and then they turned it
into the big giant University right yeah
so they both they were both Mormon even
before they met they met through Mormon
Church in the Mormon College yes yes
both ended up there somehow okay and
being from a Mormon family do you have
lots of brothers and sisters not as many
as a lot of Mormon okay I think my
parents were like whoa raising kids is
really hard I think we're done so I have
two siblings to see younger and younger
younger sister
so you're the oldest yes I'm the oldest
and okay so what was growing up like I
mean what was your house like and what
were you into it was Jo
like I had a good you know upbringing
but when I was a teenager a lot of
things started to change for me and my
political awakening so you know I am
really close to my family we're really
tight and our to this day we kind of
have like that you know we're blood we
stick together mentality but there are
some kind of real cracks in that right
because of our political differences so
did you your political awakening how did
that happen is that like because you met
like hikers in Utah that's how it works
right there's like Mormons in Utah and
there's like rock climbers they like
they like have different ideas about
their the world yeah religion yeah
that's true but my awakening was not in
Utah it was in Sacramento because I was
a teenager in Sacramento I was starting
to which is a little bit different than
in Utah in a lot of ways actually Oh
hikers and there are some but that's a
different story
yeah no it's it's a much more liberal
place but still pretty conservative by
California's yeah it's right so I just
kind of felt like at odds with a lot of
the ideas that I was being fed and just
sort of felt really critical of a lot of
the religious stuff that I had been
brought up to believe was the truth
about the world so do you remember like
thinking you know I think a lot of
people I think a lot of people from a
religious background probably go through
this where they're just sort of like mmm
I don't know if I buy this sometimes
it's sometimes it's you hear a different
perspective sometimes it's just it kind
of just hits you do you remember like a
seminal event yes there was a seminal
event when I was in the church they
separate you out by gender so all the
women go to certain classes and all the
young men go to certain classes and the
classes I was taking were like about
raising a family getting prepared to
have kids cooking sewing this very the
community was all around very
traditional gender roles and I was kind
of like I've always been a massive nerd
and I wanted to be a doctor I was so set
on it you know by the time when I was
like nine years old I was like I want to
be a gynecologist I was all about it
like I was ready to do the vagina thing
and then the Mormon Church sort of you
know made my dreams come crashing down
so as a nine-year-old you wanted to be a
gynecologist yes how did the funniest
well I mean have you had you been to a
gynecologist
oh no but I knew there are baby doctors
oh you know I want it to be
I didn't say mom I want to be a
gynecologist it was more like I want to
be the one that delivers the babies and
make sure is that make sure that girls
and women are healthy right interested
in women's health stuff okay so my
parents bought me like a bunch of books
about it they totally encouraged me to
learn about it and you know that was
somebody was completely immersed in but
it's not something that's encouraged in
the church so much that was not my
experience they don't want you to go to
med school and stuff they want you to be
a mom I know it's not okay with that
right and so what you do but there's a
we you know there's always more of a
process than that right so yeah what was
it a this isn't right I'm not cool with
this let me talk to my parents about it
you know how did that that doubt begin
to express itself yeah I just I started
feeling really alienated going to church
so I tried to stop going and that's
where the conversation started to come
up right like why don't you want to go
arguing with my parents about it as a
teenager and expressing feelings of
basically what I was picking up on was a
lot of sexism in the church and I didn't
have the words for it at that time and
my parents didn't really either so it
was like a lot of fighting and clashing
over figuring out why I was no longer
willing and I slowly just moved away
from it and tried to find a new
community and that's a big part of how I
found YouTube was leaving the church
because when you're in the Mormon Church
your entire life yeah revolves around it
and everyone you know so if you decide
this feels really bad inside for me
which I did where do you go who do you
talk to in it especially at what age I
mean 15 14 yeah that's what I mean
there's so much change taking place
personally there is without any sort of
upheaval otherwise I mean there is a
only another license at this point you
can't even like
drive away oh yeah it's like the worst
feeling ever when you're a teenager you
have no control you know you just want
so much control there's like this big
battle with parents and it was very much
the case for me plus all the political
stuff on top you know so it seems like
it was a it was an issue with the values
right you know even in your draw my life
video when you put them you have the
Mormon Church up on the whiteboard you
write sexist racist homophobic around
that you all say that what you write was
that a was it mostly that the sort of
the value issue that like I don't agree
with these values was there any of the
like which is all often happens like an
intellectual like I also don't believe
what they believe this stuff about X Y &
Z that I'm gonna have a planet or
whatever and there's lots of
mischaracterization about that but
there's a lot of weird stuff that's real
so was that any part of it - yeah I
think that came later for me
because I started to doubt all the
general stuff and then I started
thinking more critically about what I
was being told and opening my mind about
the world and maybe what trying to seek
truth right trying to figure out my own
truth figure out who I am what I believe
and when I started looking more into it
yeah there's a lot of weird stuff and it
doesn't make sense and also I was really
into science so it was like this does
not fit with the scientific view of the
world and that was a big conflict - like
religion or science which and I was very
you know already heading away from
religion so science just kind of nailed
the you know the hammer and the car the
nail in the coffin for me yeah you don't
want to bury the hammer or to get out if
you accidentally get buried alive only
bury the hammer if you're also being
buried right so did you at that time did
what was the relationship with your
parents and and also how much younger
were the your brothers and your brother
and sister at what point like during
this like 14 15 16 questioning yeah it
wasn't a good at that point my
relationship with my parents was not
great you know that was where I think a
lot of our conflicts begin because we
were fighting a lot about our values
our beliefs about the church about God
whether or not God exists and I became
very staunchly atheist when I was about
16 or 17 and like really got into that
whole thing you know there's a big
atheist community online yeah that was a
part of my coming-of-age
I don't really identify with that
anymore but it helped me have like a
place that I could feel like oh this is
where I belong right place for me so
without a license
you're a way to get away and to
establish your own sense of self apart
from the church and your immediate
family was the Internet
yes atheist community online mm-hmm and
also YouTube okay yes how do you tube
fit into that um YouTube was where a lot
of people were making videos about their
religious flight people talking about
being alienated by their beliefs or
their parents beliefs there's a lot
teenagers and stuff on there older
people as well did you start making the
videos then - yes so you you followed
suit he said I can make one of those -
I'm just not gonna watch I'd be a
consumer I'm gonna be a contributor
right yeah and I actually didn't start
making videos about the religion stuff I
started making videos about homophobia
that's my that was maybe but homophobia
in the church so I was talking about I
was talking about a lot of issues I
talked about today as I experienced them
in the church and that's kind of where I
jumped onto the YouTube bandwagon and so
that process okay so when did you start
YouTube how old were you at the time I
was 18 17 or 18 okay yeah and then it's
a right you're starting and then you go
off to college yes I actually went off
to college when I was fifteen oh yeah I
graduated really early but I did the
community college things I still lived
at home but yeah I was already in
college of it okay so around that time
so yes because let's talk about tell us
about how the you know obviously already
said that at age nine you were like I
want to be a gynecologist but when the
sex education thing you know became an
interest and also began to incorporate
itself into your content yeah I think
when I started becoming sexually active
was when that
came on my mind which was about you know
18 17 18 sex is a big part of your life
as a teenager you're having all these
new feelings and these experiences and I
felt very ill equipped to handle it all
and so it became an interest of mine you
know I just kind of learned everything
that I could absorbed everything that I
could about sexuality and gender and all
these issues that were affecting me and
I thought hey there are probably other
people out there who don't who feel the
same way as I do right they don't have
the answers they don't have anyone to
talk to
let's start a community here and that's
when I sort of shifted gears and I was
doing a lot of sex ed stuff on my
college campus when I went to Berkeley
around that time so it all kind of fit
together for me right and so you made a
youtube video called how to make fluffy
chocolate chip muffin exclamation point
yeah that was a great application
my god the digging skills well it's
online that's your in fairness the first
video that at least is still public I
don't know how many you've private it
yeah it's about birth control the
NuvaRing
review you're reviewing that yes yes and
and and then you had an update going off
of the NuvaRing a little bit later and
then there were you know it seemed like
you were kind of finding your way it
became less about chocolate chip muffins
and more about sex education on your
channel don't be fooled though my life
is still very much about real that's
real yeah no it I think like I just was
uploading something what was interesting
to me I like a lot of youtubers right
they just upload like random stuff and
they find their way
and seeing what resonates yeah with the
audience and also what makes me feel
excited the kind of content I want to
make and that makes me feel fulfilled
and proud of what I'm putting online so
the Nexus was sex there we go it's
actually very fitting ya know that the
sex stuff was relevant and also I I
found a lot of people want a place to
talk about it there wasn't really
anywhere online
there's more places now to talk about
that stuff as a teenager but it really
wasn't and especially not on YouTube the
only stuff that was talking about
sexuality on YouTube was sexy it was
like yeah right
hey like here's this vibrator come check
it out I have to be 18 or older watch
the video you know it wasn't like let's
talk about the experience of figuring
out sex as an 18 year old and do you
feel I mean you kind of already said
this early on when you said that you
felt like your background in the Mormon
Church really contributed to you know
your perspective and what you're doing
now it almost feels like your background
and sort of the philosophy of the Mormon
Church is a compass an anti compass for
where you want to take things it's like
yeah you know I'm gonna go in the exact
opposite direction of what I saw that
that perspective accomplished at first
definitely there was like a lot like I
said that the whole atheist thing it was
definitely a rebellious thing but now I
don't feel like it's so much just trying
to not be the Mormon Church I actually
have much more respect for the place of
religions now and like what religion the
intersections between religion and
sexuality my viewpoint has matured and I
think that you know a lot of people
because of my past see me as like the
anti that's not the case and part of it
is because I don't talk about that part
anymore how am i abused of religion a
God in the world I've evolved that's not
what I do online anymore so kind of like
in this sense like a lot of people are
stuck with my 17 year old self online in
a lot of ways right
well it's interesting cuz I'd say still
probably the majority of the world still
kind of gets their perspective on
sexuality from some holy book whether
that's the Quran or the Bible the Book
of Mormon
right and so it's like it's a lot of
well this has been prescribed by God and
so therefore I'm going to this is what
I'm gonna do so as someone who is you
know like you said it's not like some
rebellious rejection at this point but
it was a rejection and you don't
prescribe subscribe to that anymore so
where do your guiding principles for the
advice that you give where does that
come from well my philosophy has become
one that sexuality is a part of life
it's natural it's healthy
we need to be safe about it we need to
be real about it we need to arm people
with information knowledge is power you
know all that good stuff and I think
that the guiding philosophy is there's
nothing wrong with your body there's
nothing wrong with sexuality really what
we want to do is be real about how
people feel and make sure that they're
equipped to be safe
so that we can minimize harm right right
like in public health rooms I'm very
much about harm reduction I'm not about
telling you what to do what not to do
but to figure out how to do whatever
you're gonna do in the safest way
possible so when I'm giving advice
people about relationships or sexuality
or gender or whatever it's very focused
on taking care of the person and making
sure that they're safe what about when
it comes to harm of the heart you know
as a dad you know I'm very much
concerned about the the health of my
kids hearts you know and important thing
to be healthy and helping them navigate
you know the realities of sexuality
what's your interface with that you know
you're not your audience is mom or even
their older sister I know you're saying
you're trying to be their friend but it
starts to get a little more dicey when
you're talking about the health of
someone's heart and then okay what does
that mean about monogamy yes oh there's
a lot of big tricky questions but is
like a human being outside of the
internet and figuring out when you say
of the heart though is she's of the
heart what do you what do you mean by
that
like no feelings or their soul
emotionally in the simplest form in
contrast to when you talk about safe sex
and you say okay well safe sex
physically and what that you're not
gonna get STD or the I'm not gonna have
any emotional wanted pregnancy the
emotional side of sexuality yeah I think
I do address that too because I think
well what we know from the research and
there's been a lot of research on this
because of all the abstinence programs
is we know when we aren't people with
information about the physical stuff and
help them feel empowered about their
bodies they do actually wait longer to
do sexual stuff so I think that that's
healthy I think that kids should should
wait you know a little longer
a lot of them do and the best way to do
that is not to say you need to stop and
you know suppress all of your feelings
they're not okay this is wrong you need
to wait and wag your finger but - I'm
done with information and have the
conversation about what it means to be
ready to have sex you know what does it
mean to have a relationship with someone
what are the things that come up can we
talk about that openly can we figure
that out instead of telling people what
to do it's really the telling what to do
and always with the best of intentions
right I actually think that the absence
movement does have some good intentions
at heart they just want to protect the
heart right but it's misguided because
that's not how it's not what teenagers
respond to and that's not how we're
actually gonna protect them it's maybe a
little counterintuitive but it doesn't
work that way both in my experience and
by the data you know right it shows us
that's not how the way out there
so what do you say to your audience
about the emotional impacts of becoming
sexually active if you're talking to
like kids who were yeah explore that
yeah so a lot of the stuff I mean I talk
mostly to women right and a lot of what
I talk to young women about is it's okay
to say no and it's important to have
someone respect to your body and respect
your boundaries and empowering them
personally to know that they can say and
do what they want to do and a lot of the
time they're feeling pressured to have
sex if you say hey your decisions are
your decisions and it's totally valid
let's talk about what those feelings or
how where you're at with it they feel
empowered to wait a little longer right
and to protect themselves more I just
yeah the second way you were going bad
definitely and I guess my only other my
curiosity was the the why behind waiting
because it's easy to talk about the
mechanics of the biology of it or even
the empowerment of this it's my decision
but then the impact of what if your
decision as a 13 year old girl is like I
want to have sex yeah you know it's like
you know how do you quantify the
emotional
and metaphysical impact of that mm-hmm
well it's tricky stuff and I think that
you know a lot of kids because we live
in such a sexually prude and
simultaneously hyper sexual culture we
have really a lot of extremes going on
kids are left without the guy didn't
really stick guidance that they need so
talking to the thirteen-year-old who
wants to have sex is very complicated
not just because you're 13 but because
of all of the the culture that exists
around this the context of the 13 year
olds life so unpacking all about stuff
is really important too which is how I
kind of came to more of the feminist
content that I put online right so I
want to empower girls as people so that
their sexuality is empowered as well and
they're making decisions based on what
they want and what's right for them do
you have somebody in mind when you're
you know an audience member in mind when
you're creating your content like who do
you picture myself like my younger me
right 15 16 17 year-old Lacey right in
that time where you were kind of all the
upheaval was happening yeah and I try to
kind of stay really in touch with that
part of myself because I think people
forget as they I forget as I'm getting
older you know you you lose some of that
raw memory of what it feels like to be
at that age and to be going through
those things right so keep holding on to
that and then speaking to that I think
is part of a big part of what I do right
and of course and one of the realities
you're making videos on YouTube I mean
that you know you're talking about these
things on YouTube you also got to be a
marketer right right and so that takes
it interesting and interesting direction
mm-hmm you know you've called some of
the your approach Frank you might say
some of your your your video titles or
Frank like dirty vaginas freaky labia
shaving pubes just a name a few okay
great well before you get into the
strategy I will say that you know
obviously you're making video videos
mostly for women but when a girl makes a
video called shaving pubes there's gonna
be a bunch of dudes watching that as
well right so do you ever look at the
analytics and think about oh this is a
house in the dirt the dirty old game
what is the dirty
man factor has over 40% no I actually my
audience is very male or female
dominated okay seventy or eighty percent
between 1325 because once they once they
get in they're like oh she's not
actually shaving her pubes they're like
okay you know okay got it I'm not I'm
not gonna be into this ya know there's
definitely some weird stuff but just
like any youtuber you just have to have
tough skin and just let it kind of roll
off your back
it definitely bothered me a lot when I
was younger the weird stuff
curvy stuff I don't really pay as much
attention to it anymore and I also think
that I command more respect because I'm
more confident now and I think that
comes through on camera I'm an adult now
when I started I was not an adult Yeah
right so I think that has changed the
way that people comment on my videos too
what is the strategy with the with the
titling the strategy is I want you to
feel entertained and you know there's a
little bit of taboo Ness right that's
okay I think that it pulls people and
you have to meet people where they're at
with these topics
that's another guiding force for me
where are people at with it not where
I'm at not where doctors are at or
public health officials they're at how
are kids talking about it and that's how
they're talking about it so I want to
speak the language that I know that
works and would speak to me yeah in at
the same time it doesn't hurt that
having a sensational title it bleeds
some more views right I mean that's
where all youtubers here we've tried it
all Ashley Capps freaky is where we
haven't used a lot we use crazy bizarre
insane weird we actually use bonkers
recently bonkers we literally have
meetings for a good mythical morning
team where we sit around and try to come
up with new ways to say crazy and yeah I
recently pitched bonkers one I like that
and we made a video called bonkers
summer camps I pitched and it's doing
well I pitched totes redic and I don't
think that that didn't work doesn't work
no I like rockers I might have to use
that yeah you can bring it back inside
feel free to take long
I'll credit you for Walker's what what
would it be bonkers bonkers sex bonkers
vagina with teeth okay you did talk you
did recently say that in a video not
recently but when your videos did
clarify that there are never been teeth
found in the actual vagina teeth that is
true yes I didn't know anyone was
wondering that oh I was wondering oh
people wonder you know about all kinds
of words they're like I'm like where are
you finding this what kind of weird porn
are you watching you know but but there
but you did say that teeth have been
found in like the uterus other parts
because that's not like joint wind that
didn't unjoin that's just you know what
it really is science what bonkers hahaha
man at uterus dated small net that's for
if you can always picture the voice of
the dirty when you look at your
analytics and you see that like ten
percent you just picture okay so let's
talk about that let's talk about men
let's talk about feminism because that
is a big part of your content and we're
gonna talk about Sam pepper just give
you a heads up we're gonna talk about
sample rate my favorite topic but first
let's talk about you know how do you
feel about the fact that your content
does kind of invite in some senses the
same type of thing that you're trying to
battle right because you know sexist
dudes are going to see you in a certain
way because you talk about sex frankly
as a target as a target mm-hmm does that
happen yeah of course
have you read my comments section yeah I
mean so what me said well how do you
process that mmm
I don't really anymore it's not like a
part of my regular processing I kind of
gotten over the fact that that just
happens online but yeah I mean at first
it was really upsetting to me I also
found that I get that kind of that kind
of feedback no matter what I upload it
doesn't matter that if it's about sex
although that probably just makes them
feel like they have license didn't give
any more but the fact that I'm a woman
like something like they have license
the fact that I talk about my life or
sexuality you know gives them license
there's a lot of aspects of what I do
that make them like you said see me is
it that's a target but I'm not gonna let
them you're not gonna be the trolls
you're smart enough to not feed the
troll know you're not gonna make a video
where you get upset about that behavior
no although I have made videos before
calling it out calling out that behavior
when I was younger
very badly right very learned do you
learn the lesson yeah I learned the
lesson but I think also the community
learned the lesson too like there was a
bit of an exchange I had with some
youtubers and it was a it was growing
pains but I think honestly it's not a
healthy way to handle it but it is one
of the most difficult things to resist
right when people especially when you're
younger a when people say something and
you're like that doesn't you're stupid
that doesn't that's not me you're
misrepresenting me you're
mischaracterizing me you're it's just is
so hard to not respond but they're all
they want you to do is respond yeah so
they can be legitimized that's true they
want you to legitimize them but I just
don't really care like like why do I oh
who are you I don't owe you any
explanation I don't need to defend
myself
I Know Who I am I know what this is
about the fact that you're
misrepresenting is completely different
issue and I'm not going to entertain it
Yeah right
can you give us the complete Sam pepper
story from your perspective
really the complete one just like how
you were you know like what your how it
all happened from your perspective when
people started reaching out to you and
the video you decided to make just for
people who may not know that whole story
yet so
was really awful it was like a really
bad experience for me seriously because
I have talked about sexual violence
stuff and I speak at a lot of schools
about it and so I've become like a place
that people feel like they can talk to
you about this stuff I noticed this
stuff online you know a floodgate was
open let me start the beginning the
beginning was Sam pepper is a UK
youtuber who uploads prank videos I'm
using my air quotes right now prank
videos where he grabs women on the
street he forces his mouth on them and
these videos are very uncomfortable the
women are like seriously weirded out
that this guy is putting a camera in
their face and grabbing them and making
out with them on the street and if a guy
ever did that to me I was like oh my god
he would've been punched in the face by
now do not touch me but these girls are
like oh my god you know they don't
they're shocked yeah
about what's coming on and he's making
all these videos and getting all you
know he's got tons and tons of views and
I become a little bit concerned once he
crosses a line and he starts to grab a
bunch of women's butts with the fake
hand he's like freaking them out right
so I just wrote this letter this open
letter saying hey this is not an
appropriate message to send out to your
audience it's not an appropriate way to
treat women on the street this is
harassment
it's a letter the letter so let's let's
stop for one second and say okay the
decision to write the letter what went
into that for you um feeling like I had
to say something I just was like what is
going on and people were messaging me
about it and there was a lot of upset
about it and people just sort of looked
to me as oh that's her topic can you
help us out right she talks about the
sexuality stuff she talks about sexual
violence and you chose a letter not a
vlog at first yes well I chose a letter
because I didn't want it to be such a
big thing I wanted to be low-key like
let's hope he sees this I just wanted
him to read the letter that was like a
tumblr post right yeah it's just a
tumblr post um but then all these people
started youtubers started contacting me
about the letter they were also very
upset and I realized whoa a lot of
youtubers were also feeling really
awkward about this and didn't know what
to say they want to co-sign the letter
and I started getting hundreds of people
like can you add my name can you add my
name the letter on you tumblr gets 100
thousands some notes and goes very viral
it's my most viewed I think post on
tumblr so there's a lot of community
traction around it then because you know
all the eyes were on this me talking
about Sam pepper then I started I got a
couple of emails from girls who met him
and had very concerning experiences at
places like VidCon and you know it was
two or three girls one of them was
actually in the middle of a lawsuit that
she was going to press charges against
him and was reaching out to me just to
say hey you should know that I'm
actually working on a lawsuit right now
I'm thinking about pressing charges you
know she's already in the system with
this you should know if there's other
people coming forward about this I would
like to know that just for me as a
person
um you know and I realized the situation
in the situation just got so much bigger
Remy all the sudden yeah you became a
focal point of people wanting to respond
yes and after the letter you know before
you took any other action mm-hmm at that
point did you hear anything from Sam
pepper or from you know yes Sam pepper
was messaging me and she was threatening
me on on Twitter and I was getting
emails and tweets and it was not pretty
he didn't want me to talk about it and
he was clearly trying to intimidate me a
little bit and I was like uh-huh
you're not in the wrong person I'm gonna
be intimidated by you you know and that
just sort of gave me more like urgency
to the situation if he's trying to get
me to shut up what is going on you know
like what is the situation that I've
accidentally stumbled into um and you
and you were open about the fact that he
was threatening you yeah you yeah
because I think people should should
know how he's behaving how he's
responding because I think it's really
telling ya the way they
he responded umm and concerning and I
think that people you know you talk
about it people think I'm I'm trying to
like do something for myself like people
try to make it like I was trying to get
attention like what people don't know is
I'm like the least I don't want
attention about this kind of stuff like
this is terrible
complicated messy stuff I don't want to
be you know mixed up in that you hadn't
built your career on calling out
individuals no policing
other people no in your context not my
style I prefer to talk about the issue
not the person but in this case this
person is a real predator in the
community and I was worried about him
going to conferences and I was you know
some of the things that have been
disclosed to me
details of the lawsuits you know it's
terrifying so what and so then there was
the exchange which he was making public
tweets and then so you were making
public the the exchange you were having
with him yes and then what and then
there was some a lot of stuff working
with a few people behind the scenes
there was a ton of press - oh yeah that
was a big stressor - because then all of
a sudden BBC wants to talk about this
and all these big major media outlets
and I oh my god I thought I was going to
collapse and like or like explode one or
the other right because I was also on
tour well this is going on I'm speaking
at a new university everyday about tons
of events might schedules super packed
and I got this enormous mess on my hands
online and I'm all alone you know and
you know implosion and you kind of you
really sense that when you make your
vogs and pepper exposed you're sitting
on the bed in the hotel room you look
like you have you know you're just
you're so not a willing participant in
this it's like I am so reluctantly
involved in this and speaking and you
can sense it in what you're saying yeah
I mean it was a lot of stress for me and
I didn't want to do the
wrong thing I wanted to make sure I was
handling this right I felt like I had a
lot of eyes on me I did have a lot of
eyes on me I didn't want to get myself
in legal trouble I didn't want to make
false accusations I didn't want any bad
thing to happen right I want it like
justice to be served and that's it I
need to figure out the best way that I
could facilitate that because at this
point everyone was like well Lacey will
handle it and in some ways I'm a little
bit upset that more people didn't try to
help me out like a lot of people just
preferred to watch yeah I'm not but
maybe they feel felt as helpless as I
did you know they're like I don't know
what to do and I didn't know what to do
either you know it's just a big mess so
and so when he said I was alone you you
experienced support but it was like okay
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna back you up
with what you did but and like I'll add
my name to the list or things like that
but what were you alone did you find any
help if that was a lawyer or anybody you
know like what kind of help did you find
were there any resources and I think as
a community is there a you know is there
feedback for the community at large
because I think that's that's important
to hear is that you know you there was a
lot of support externally but then
internally as you were navigating this
it sounds like maybe people didn't know
how to help yeah but how could how could
they I think that people could have been
more vocal and could have maybe it would
have been nice to have someone reach out
and be like hey do you need like help do
you need an ear do you what can I do
need some support in this um that would
have been helpful for me because I was
you know completely alone in and trying
to figure out some resources I contacted
friends of mine you know in this in the
sexual violence space I'm very
well-connected and I used to be a
counselor for the the state for
California State so I am connected to
state resources in California so that la
case was something that I felt more
equipped to handle but there was another
one in Buffalo and another one in the UK
and those situations helping them wasn't
sure how to do it handling it
publicly wasn't sure how to do it you
know wasn't sure like what the right how
do I do this this is really bad guys
like do I just right so now when you
made the video yeah like what what what
was the decision to make the video at
that point and then how did that go the
decision to make the video was needing
these conferences to kick him out that
was a big part of it and needing people
to know that this is a high risk
situation and people need to have their
eyes on this I need to pay attention to
what's going on over here we don't we
can't just sweep this under the rug
it's like a real serious issue that's
happening at these conventions um and I
felt like if I don't say it who is no
one right no one was gonna say anything
um and people did a few people said
stuff after I did but it was still a
very few people who really publicly
talked about this issue and I think was
a lot of people who I would consider a
part of the more feminist community of
LGBT community you were kind of
expecting to speak up yeah yeah not like
people who have more overlap with these
actual audiences right with with Sam
peppers audience like that is a
different community and I wanted more
people who are in that community yeah to
speak up and say hey we don't stand for
this this is not okay this is not an OK
way to interact interact with your fans
and we need to have higher standards for
ourselves and have more awareness of
what kind of content we're posting
online what kind of message we're
sending to people what are we building
our channels off of harassing women is
that gonna be your channel theme right
like is that acceptable no it's not
acceptable and I feel like nobody wants
to say that nobody wants to talk about
that and especially not people who are
more you know further away from my
community right and so the the aftermath
of you kind of bringing these things to
light you know the accusations and
and these things it I mean it pretty
this pretty much did him in I mean
really you know he got dropped by his
Network he kind of went away from
YouTube for a good while he was
blacklisted from VidCon as an example
maybe playlists and other conferences
but you made a follow a video video
where you kind of explained that you
felt like appropriate action had not
really been taking thing and things had
not gone far enough
that's right I think he should be in
jail I absolutely do
he should not be running around in the
world and you know I am aware I don't I
can't follow him because it's really
upsetting to me but like my friends kind
of keep an eye on him and let me know
and he's still doing some shady stuff
you know I know he's still doing and I
don't I feel helpless I don't know what
I don't know so for me I've just had to
see like he's still making youtube
videos um I don't know if he's still
making YouTube videos some of the
situations that I've heard about have
happened over snapchat cuz he uses
snapchat okay so um yeah there's still
there's very much unrest in my soul
about this situation yeah in that video
was the earliest of that unrest but it's
still there and it's not just about Sam
pepper either it's about you know
feeling like Oh YouTube is such a utopia
in a lot of ways but here's this like
dark part that we have to confront yeah
and no one wants to and it's really
uncomfortable and no one knows how I'm
feeling like I'm the only person it's
like I don't feel equipped if I don't
feel equipped who does well yeah I could
say from from my perspective just to you
know encourage you somewhat you may feel
like you know justice hasn't been served
specifically with him but I would say
that you impacted the culture of YouTube
prank videos in a significant way
I said I'm not I'm not saying that it
stopped yeah but I'm saying that I feel
like there are a lot of people out there
who may have supported or liked a video
but now they think about is someone
being taken advantage of what is the
motivation behind this
yeah I mean it made me I mean obviously
that that particular video where he's
grabbing the butts was theirs he's
crossed so many lines that it's you
every most people are like okay this is
unacceptable but I think there's so many
other videos that got close to that line
approached that line that we're really
already breaking in a line and I think
you know it makes other people be more
sensitive to it yes I so I think you
know it's not like the battle isn't over
by any means but you contributed it you
threw a large bomb out there that was
effective thank you I that is very nice
to hear um because I often feel defeated
like you know it hasn't changed and you
know when you're an activist it's easy
to just kind of focus on what's wrong
instead of what's right like you know
focusing on wow there's still so much on
there like what do I do instead of
acknowledging what you just said right
yeah so we have to take what we can get
yeah and I think the another thing we
want to talk about quickly is you know
there's the overt stuff the obvious
taking advantage of women in the way
that Sam did in his videos and
apparently in private too but then
there's the more subtle sexism right and
you got a couple of guys like mid-30s
maybe even older than that now growing
up in North Carolina and surrounded by
tobacco fields mm-hmm
there's you know there's no doubt that
we say inadvertently saying let's leave
tobacco out of this why you gotta
complicate it with tobacco because
that's that's just miss them oh crap
okay all right forget the tobacco just
trying to set us yeah so what are they
inadvertently or maybe you know I don't
know maybe it's not inadvertent what are
the sexist things that you hear being
said see being done that it's just like
okay you guys should know about this
stop saying this stop doing this online
like on YouTube or in my effort in
either whatever come to my things that
we need to stop saying that maybe not
you've heard us say it yeah like that
yeah I think for me as a woman one of
them
I a recurring experience of sex sexism
it's constantly being reduced to how I
look and I think that we all do this to
each other to some extent but I think
women kind of get a really raw the raw
end of the deal
on this and also being on camera all the
time you know feeling like everyone's
very judgy of women and and people don't
listen to what I'm saying and it's been
such a battle to be like did you hear
the words that just came out of my mouth
like I just said them are you hello are
you there and I don't think that that's
necessarily like Oh on YouTube thing
that's just my interactions in life but
on YouTube I think that people need to
be aware of representing how we're
representing women and kind of making
sure that it we're leveling the playing
field this is a new media platform
that's amazing and exciting and a lot of
you know we have to be careful or the
the patterns and the trends and the
problems that are in traditional media
will come in and affect this platform
like we have this great opportunity we
have to be aware though so that we can
make sure that you know girls and people
of color and the LGBT community are all
having an equal opportunity on this
platform as well and that's kind of the
stuff that I do at VidCon is what a lot
of working on making sure that the
issues that those communities are facing
are being addressed so that we can all
have fun on on YouTube do you feel like
you're gonna have to step up and call
more people on the carpet like it sounds
like it's the last thing that you want
to do from just a personal quality of
life standpoint to go through that again
but is there uh is there a need for that
or for you to start calling more more
instances out like I mean that you've
got the video about sexism in horror
movies mm-hmm
but it's not like you're looking at the
latest movie that just came out and
you're like picking apart the Fast and
the Furious 7 mm-hmm have you thought
about something like that in in general
I do the stuff I do with MTV
my MTV braless stuff that is more along
those lines okay it's more along the
looking at like current pop culture and
current events and stuff and people and
looking at the conversations that are
happening and dissecting that more but I
don't like as it's like my personality I
don't like conflict and I don't like you
know the prote I struggle with how to
approach calling someone out as you say
right because I don't I don't want to
like complicate it and make it a
personal vendetta it's it's because it's
not about the person it's about a
behavior or something but it gets
personal something sense how does the
MTV show work what's the format they're
having not seen it yeah it's just like a
feminist pop culture analysis my
analysis of stuff is what do you shoot
it you go into a studio in LA this is
not like it's in Oakland the studios in
Oakland
yeah the sets in Oakland and we have a
crew there and we shoot every week it's
like we do seasons
so there's on and off seasons we're in
the third season right now
and it's just you know we're kind of
looking at stuff that's relevant to the
MTV audience and adding a little bit of
an academic flare and adding a little
bit of social commentary and kind of
giving people new ways to look at
different situations that are happening
like we did some stuff about Mad Max and
you know about all kinds of movies Magic
Mike and Beyonce Nicki Minaj and we're
talking about all these things through
the feminist lens through an
understanding of you know gender and
what's the filter there how do you apply
that filter to your music videos your
music not your you know your your
run-of-the-mill music video whether it
be a Nicki Minaj or something where it's
I mean it then the era of 90s rap music
videos if it's changed a little bit but
not enough I would imagine in your view
yeah the objectification of women and
music videos yeah well of course when we
talk about that a lot
I'm braless and like all the different
angles of it tell people really
understand
what it looks like to help them
understand how to identify it and why
it's a problem and what the difference
is - with objectification stop what the
difference is between objectifying
someone and just being sexual because
sometimes people are like oh we're not
allowed to be sexual anymore women can't
be sexy I'm not allowed to look at their
bodies are you delineate well the
difference is who's the consumer and who
is you know who's who's got the power
like Nicki Minaj we've talked about her
videos is it objectifying do people
objectify her absolutely
but she is the one that is in control of
it you know she is the one that is
choosing it's her sexuality she's
expressing her sexuality and it's like
well what a it's not that simple right
no it's not that simple but that's a big
part of it is empowering women to be
sexual and identifying situations where
women are being told they have to be
sexual in order to make money or
whatever and that's where it gets
complicated right mm-hmm
it is it is complicated right because
you've got okay well maybe a woman is
making the choice but maybe she's being
influenced by the culture yeah oh and
what heard the expectations of her body
and how she should present her body
which aren't necessarily expectations
that she set yes you know what I mean
yes absolutely and so it's that context
that that type of context for a lot of
things that are going on in the world
and in the media that we're looking at
it's not like making this is bad this is
good this is right this is wrong that's
not my approach my approach is let's
take a look at all the angles here and
kind of figure out the best most just
most informed way to digest these
situations something yeah so do you like
Nicki Minaj I do I think she's done like
some weird stuff like the Nazi video
like what was that I don't know what is
the will overlook that maybe she didn't
know it maybe yeah I mean people are
complex they're complicated they're not
just good people or bad people people do
complicated things right well thanks for
allowing us to explore the complexities
of everything that is your life
this podcast yeah of course no thank you
for inviting me I feel like this is a
little bit of a therapy session on this
we should've brought the couch oh yeah
is the Kleenex box next time we'll do
that well what so what's the conclusion
if it felt like therapy for you I think
we sent her a bill I think all right
we'll look for that there you have it
our ear biscuit with Laci green let her
know what you thought about the
conversation you can do that on the
Twitter her handle is Go Green 18 Go
Green 18 make sure you use hashtag ear
biscuits yeah we love it when you give
feedback also when you leave a review
for us and this podcast on iTunes or
comment along with us on soundcloud sex
education I feel like I was educated
yeah I learned some stuff about 37 year
old man and and you know it was
challenging at the end there so we don't
need to rehash that but I will just say
that I appreciated what Lacey had to say
and that gave us a lot to think about as
members of this community and how we
should stand up when someone's doing the
right thing and help them and support
him in that
and she's also just you know she is one
of the only people focusing on this kind
of content and she's not you know
despite the fact that she titles her
videos in a certain way to give you
she's actually doing it also because it
is she wants to be able to have a frank
unapologetic conversation about sex
because she thinks that that's important
for people to know about it in a in a
frank way which I think makes me think
about our experience just growing up and
how I mean I there was no YouTube there
was no Laci green so how did you at
first hear about sex I mean how did you
well what was the world how was it
opened up to you soon
my mom she worked for the health
department that's convenient back in
Harnick County and it turns out that in
the lobby of her workplace they have all
types of sex education pamphlets oh yeah
pamphlets are very helpful one of with
stick figures oh gosh and one of one of
which she decided to give to me and she
said all right this is gonna teach you
some things you need to know as as a boy
who's you know starting to go through
puberty and figures figuring things out
yeah there's how old were you I don't
remember that but when I got the
pamphlet maybe I don't know I might have
been 12 mm-hmm I went I was like okay
she was like if you have any questions
ask me but she didn't like read it to me
like a bedtime story right she gave it
to me and I went into my room and then I
went into my closet okay close the door
to my room closed the door to my closet
sat in the closet in the dark with a
flashlight and read this pamphlet you
were that scared of it I was were you
scared up she but the funny thing is is
you took all the steps that someone
who's trying to hide something from
their mom takes but your mom had given
you the shampoo and you didn't have
anybody else in the house who are you
hiding from yeah I didn't have any
siblings
I just felt like it was the type of
thing you want to be in like a secret
like secret place to like read but I
think that that is indicative or it's
very telling of you know up to that
point what you thought about it you're
right this is this is like secret
information that you should you don't
want to talk about openly and there's
it's it could be shameful I don't know
it's I don't know exactly what I was
thinking but I felt that my hide yeah
which I think kind of speaks to why lacy
has felt the need to talk about things
in the way that she does I mean because
you know I also think it's generational
because I think that we're going to be a
lot more apt to talk about sex with our
kids so that'll make sure that they're
educated more so than we were because my
parents didn't work at a health
department and they didn't there were no
pamphlets and no stick figures there was
just figuring it out through you know
conversations with friends
inference yeah right which I don't
necessarily think it's the most healthy
way to do to learn about it it's never
like a definitive birds and bees
conversation with your parents no no no
pamphlet no pamphlet a night you know
and I don't I mean honestly I don't
really hold it against him because I
don't I don't think many people I think
you actually were probably in the
minority at the time in the place where
we were with parents that were having
open frank conversations about sex with
her kids I've I went it's cuz she had
the pamphlet she didn't even have a
conversation she gave you a pamphlet I
mean let's just be honest I mean but
that's better than the raffle --it I
also went to visit my dad one weekend
around the same time and I learned a lot
by watching Lethal Weapon
- Wow yeah well there's a there's a
scene where you can learn a lot right I
learned at least one from one scene
there yeah and that's probably not the
most healthy way to learn well it it
sinks in pretty quickly it's still there
it still stinks in it instead yeah okay
I didn't think I should be I've been
watching that at that age so yeah that
was probably a healthy I didn't tell
anybody instinct but you didn't go in a
closet and watch it because there was
nothing like there was no small like VCR
yeah you couldn't get like a little iPod
in there that didn't exist no it did you
couldn't get a whole cabinet with a TV
inside of it inside a closet - then
watch Lethal Weapon 3 to be tooken -
well he lived in a mobile home I
remember okay we'll bring another
educational episode of your biscuits at
your ears next week and it probably
won't relate to sex because we got a lot
of that this week yeah we did but maybe
hey I don't know
[Music]
[Music]